su médico puede recomendarle una terapia
de reemplazo con testosterona si el
nivel de testosterona en su torrente
sanguíneo es significativamente menor
que el normal
la testosterona es una hormona masculina
también llamada andrógenos que se
produce en sus testículos la
testosterona promueve el desarrollo de
características sexuales masculinas y
apoya las funciones masculinas tal como
la producción de esperma y el deseo
sexual
esta hormona es también esencial para el
mantenimiento de la densidad ósea
el nivel de glóbulos rojos la masa
muscular y la sensación de bienestar
y los niveles bajos de testosterona en
su sangre pueden resultar en una
condición llamada deficiencia
androgénica o hipogonadismo que puede
incluir el aumento de grasa corporal
tamaño reducido de los músculos y pechos
hinchados
si su nivel de testosterona es bajo
puede experimentar un impulso sexual
disminuido disfunción eréctil y baja
cantidad de esperma lo que lleva a la
infertilidad una deficiencia en
testosterona afecta a todas las partes
de su cuerpo incluso puede causar
pérdida del vello corporal aumento de
grasa corporal disminución de masa
muscular disminución de densidad ósea
que puede llevar a osteoporosis anemia
suave pechos hinchados o sensibles
bochornos disminución de energía y
depresión
y la terapia de reemplazo con
testosterona es la administración de
testosterona producida por el hombre
para elevar el nivel de esta hormona en
su sangre a su nivel normal y aliviar
sus síntomas
puede realizar la terapia con
testosterona con una inyección parche
o pastillas
si recibe inyecciones recibirá una cada
dos o tres semanas
y la testosterona se aplicará en el
músculo de sus nalgas
si usa un parche de testosterona para la
piel colocará el parche en su brazo
espalda
y abdomen o parte superior de sus nalgas
cambiará su parche diariamente si usa un
gel de testosterona lo aplicará
diariamente a la piel en su hombro
antebrazo o abdomen
si usa pastillas bucales colocará una
pastilla en su línea gingival dos veces
al día